we've got a fox news alert for you there
is new exclusive information coming in
right now about the police response to
that massacre at Stoneman Douglas High
School in Florida Fox's Matt fin has
been working in sources all day and
joins us with what he has found Matt
Tucker new tonight there are some heavy
allegations against the commanding
officer running the scene the day of the
shooting at Stoneman Douglas High School
multiple law enforcement sources allege
that the commanding officer prematurely
gave responding deputies orders to stage
and form a perimeter outside during
critical moments after the shootings
when they say all deputies should have
been running towards the school to
neutralize the shooter one law
enforcement source says the alleged that
command goes against all training to go
go go towards the shooter another law
enforcement officer said the alleged bad
commands could have been detrimental to
victims every second is another life we
spoke with multiple sources in law
enforcement at the city and county level
who say they heard the scene that day
was chaotic the Broward County Sheriff's
Office active shooter policy indicates
the first priority for responding
deputies is to enter the structure to
preserve life staging and a perimeter
apparently not listed as a priority all
the sources allegations seem to be
backed up by a copy of the dispatch call
law from the shooting that day obtained
by Fox News which appears to indicate
several commands for deputies to stage
or form a perimeter when calls were
still going across the radio that the
shooters ID and whereabouts were not
known what a source call is still a very
active situation however at least two
law enforcement sources we spoke to say
the state's investigation into the
timeline that day will reveal if the
calls for deputies to stage outside was
the right call because staging
eventually has to happen at every scene
each emergency situation is unique the
commander that day may have known
something the rest of the crews did not
we asked the Broward County Sheriff's
Office or common we also asked the
Florida Department of Law Enforcement
which is investigating the sheriff's
office for comment and each said that
this is an active investigation that
they cannot comment on it and they will
eventually reveal their timelines Tucker
Matt fin thanks a lot for that pretty
remarkable